i'm okay if i don't become the ultimate
version of what i could become
but i won't tolerate not trying the
people that win are not the smartest
it is always the people that keep at it
it's the people that persevere it does
not matter who you are today
the only thing that matters
is who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best tom bilyeu
and my take on his top 10 rules for
success enjoy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one give it your all
have a vision of the person you could
become
and to reach the pearly gates as it were
see who you could have been contrast it
with who you actually are and be
disappointed by the gap between them
and i love chasing that i think it's a
beautiful chase
but what i hope you guys will do if you
ever find yourself at the pearly gates
disappointed in how much farther you
could have gone
to simply ask one question of yourself
every day
did i give it my all today
doesn't mean you're always gonna win
yeah
if your life is a series of
yes i did
you've won
you've won guys the struggle is
guaranteed the struggle is guaranteed
the struggle is guaranteed
the success is not
and like the thing that i beg you guys
is to have the guts
to fail at something that you love
and when you were on the mud on your
face and people are laughing
the i told you so's are coming out
that you remember one simple fact
you loved what you were doing
and you left it out on the field
what the [ __ ] else is there
legitimately like i'm getting emotional
what the [ __ ] else is there what more
can you ask of yourself than to really
try to really say i give a [ __ ] about
this
that's the life to live that's the life
like to say i care about this it matters
it gives me purpose i'm going to fight
for this this is a group of people i
want to serve
and i'm going to go all the way out
every day and look you're not going to
hit it every day there's going to be
days where you're off there's going to
be days where you're weak
weak
but if that day instead of bullshiting
yourself instead of saying i wasn't weak
today what are you talking about if that
day you own it and you say yeah it was
week today and i'm not going to be weak
tomorrow but i'm not afraid to face that
i'm not afraid to accept that i'm not
perfect i'm not afraid to look in the
mirror and say today was a bad day that
i didn't make myself proud today but
that shouldn't diminish who you are i
shouldn't diminish your view of yourself
why because i wouldn't serve you
because if you beat yourself up today
you make it harder for you to be rad
tomorrow
it's a game that has to be seen in total
it's not a game where you can take a
snapshot and this is like what i want
you guys to understand in any one moment
i've looked like a fool so many times i
can't count
but when i look at my life in ten year
chunks i'm freaked out by what i've
accomplished
so i'm okay if i don't become the
ultimate version of what i could become
but i won't tolerate not trying rule
number two know your identity my
identity is wrapped up in if i promise
myself i'm gonna do something i'm gonna
do it that's big to me even if nobody's
looking that's really big and so i know
how i want to feel about myself when i
say that and so i adhere to it just
because of that and i cannot tell you
that that desire to feel a certain way
about myself because i've constructed an
identity i've told other people what my
identity is and i want to feel that like
i want to be impressed with myself
that's the reality i want to feel that
like pride when i say it or when i'm all
alone and i'm thinking about who i am
and how i'm acting that feeling to me is
so intoxicating that i have to act in
accordance with that that probably comes
up in my life
it's got to be close to 10 times a day a
day because i'll want to relax i'll want
to let off the gas pedal i'll have just
been doing something and i'll be like
exhausted and bored with it and i want
to go like do something fun and i'll be
like no no like i could literally just
go do this and no one would know
and
yeah i would know and so that keeps me
in check so identity drives behavior
that's the big one rule number three be
the learner at moments
at moments where i'm bone tired
i have that clarity
and when you have the clarity and you
know where you're trying to go
then it becomes clear about what you
have to train at what are the things you
have to train into yourself but the only
way to do that is to have a self-esteem
that's built entirely around being the
learner why
because you get the shot to the head the
nugget of gold at your feet it says you
suck at this
that hurts man that's hard to own it's
hard to face
and there's a thousand voices in your
mind telling you all the reasons why
it's somebody else's fault and it's not
your fault
but the reality is the moment you do
that you're giving away your power
because you're not looking for a way to
change
you're not looking for a way to shape
your skill set remember between where
you are and where you want to go it is a
gap of skill set
now i'm not a born entrepreneur i don't
have any entrepreneurial instincts by
birth
when i first got involved in business i
remember my only contributions to
our conference calls you're going to
think i'm kidding and this is
unfortunately very true the only
contribution i would make to a
conference call was to say goodbye
and i remember i used to get so excited
here it comes we're wrapping up this is
going to be amazing it's my chance
goodbye
and i finally i got to say something
but at that time i just needed to learn
i needed to pay attention i needed to
see where i was weak and the constant
barrage on my self-esteem that i wasn't
the smartest person in the room that i
wasn't right very often it was
unrelenting
and i remember saying to myself
all right man you got two choices
you can leave like you don't need to be
here you don't need to want to become an
entrepreneur that doesn't have to be
your life
you can go back to selling video games
which is what i was doing
you can go back to selling video games
you could go back to teaching
like if that's where you're going to be
happy
then go do that
but if you really want to become
extraordinary you've got to separate
your self-esteem from being wrong you
have to
because otherwise you're never going to
see the opportunity to get better and so
i decided that i was going to start
valuing myself my entire value was going
to be predicated on being willing to
admit that i was wrong
on being willing to stare nakedly at my
inadequacies i was not going to hide
from them i was not going to run i
wasn't going to try to do some fancy
story i was just going to own it yo you
suck at this man
you suck at this but
you're just not good at it yet
and once that word yet is lingering out
there suddenly it becomes a question of
time allocation
so you know you could get good at it but
it's going to take a lot of time and
energy so what are the skills you really
want to get good at and that goes back
to that clarity what do i need to get
good at in order to accomplish the
things that i want to accomplish it does
not need to be something that somebody
else values it needs to be the thing i
have chosen to value that i've built
into my life this worship around getting
good at that thing i didn't have to get
good at helping others build mindset
that didn't have to be my life
but that's what i've chosen that's what
i want to do and so i build this
tremendous amount of value into it and
because i value myself for pursuing that
and i value myself for admitting when
i'm wrong and i value myself for staring
nakedly at my inadequacies every
day i'm getting better rule number four
believe in yourself once you have your
goal then you can work backwards to what
you need to do in order to accomplish
that goal
and that
is the chasm of adaptation
it's the acquisition of skill set
it's getting better at something
it's becoming capable of something that
you weren't capable of before
but that change
the fear of the unknown
is the thing that paralyzes
people so i want to go back to what i
said earlier
you all meet minimum requirements
and i really mean that i don't want
you to wonder if somebody believes in
you
i believe in you
i've seen a lot of people
reach for the stars
and fail
i've seen a lot of people reach for the
stars and make it
i have a pretty good sense
of what it takes for people to get there
so when i say that you guys meet minimum
requirements i really mean it
and i want that to liberate you
but what i wanted to liberate you to do
is to figure out why
it's not enough
because i didn't just change anyone's
life with that phrase but i should have
that should be all you need to know
but there are other things stuck in your
perception
of who you are
in the lens by which you view this world
that convinces you that you can't make
it
all right what is up everybody i want to
talk to you about my good friend evan
carmichael's book
right here built to serve i'm actually
going to read you a section there are
some amazing parts of this book and this
is one of my favorite it's under the
title comfort is the enemy of greatness
and it goes when you're comfortable you
don't get strong when you have plenty of
fresh air and no adversity you crumble
as soon as something gets hard it's
rarely the kids of rich parents who go
on to do great things even though they
have all the advantages that money
connections and education
can buy
why is that because they're too
comfortable people who are comfortable
don't create great things there it is
evan carmichael bringing the heat in his
book
built to serve get a copy rule number
five keep at it humans are designed to
adapt we are the ultimate adaptation
machine we can learn anything we set our
minds to now you may not want to learn
it and that's good evidence that this is
not a fascination that's going to turn
into a passion this is something that
you should avoid but if you can answer
the question
affirmatively that do i want to know
more about this than anyone else in the
world if the answer is yes that's a path
to go down because once you're saying
yes to that then you're going to go in
and learn the things you need to do to
become extraordinary and if you're
willing to put in the effort while it
may take you longer than somebody else
you will get there in the end if you
keep at it keep at it keep at it because
the people that win are not the smartest
it is always the people that keep at it
it's the people that persevere that's
just truth man now being smart helps yay
i really wish i was a lot smarter so but
i know that i'll beat 99.999 percent of
the people that play regardless of level
of intelligence because most people just
drop out rule number six be willing to
pay the price remember that just 15
years earlier
i got out of bed solely out of shame
my mother thought i was going to fail
my father-in-law did not want me to
marry his daughter
brick
by brick
day after day
i transformed myself
it was not an uncovering of something
that was real and already there
it was simply acknowledging i am a
hopelessly average human
but humans are the ultimate adaptation
machine
so i can change i can become whatever i
want
and i just became single mindedly
focused on how much i could grow and now
that i was getting value and self-esteem
out of growing
instead of out of being
everything in my life changed
so 15 years later
my father-in-law visits
the us for the first time since we
started quest
and i'm taking him around the production
floor
and there's
300 000 square feet there's 800
employees the bars are coming off the
line at 1.5 million a day people are
coming up and thanking me for having a
job and for the way that we run the
company and all that
and i turned to him and i said andreas
do you remember asking me how i was
going to take care of your daughter and
he said yes
and i said how am i doing
and he just burst into tears
and the punch line of that story
it does not matter who you are today the
only thing that matters
is who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there rule number seven want it
motivation you have to want it it has to
be something that you are on fire for
literally as you were describing it i
was like oh my god i would study so much
i would ace this exam you have no idea i
would absolutely kill this
because that's my identity
so why is it that you want to do this is
it that you want to be the best is it
just the promotion if it's the promotion
and this is just about money what does
that mean why does it matter what are
you going to do with the money are you
the first person in your family to be
promoted that far are you setting an
example for your son or your daughter
like when you attach it to something
that really matters like for me it's
like i'm gonna dominate wherever you put
me i'm gonna dominate that's just my
thing
my identity is so wrapped up in
outworking everybody else
i love it so i love going hard learning
putting more time and energy my thing is
part of my identity you ready for the
secret
part of my identity is like i will work
so hard at something that people will
just assume i'm naturally gifted at that
thing because the alternative to believe
that i'm spending
40 hours a week
40 hours a week on top of my full-time
job to study for that thing people they
won't believe that i would put that kind
of energy and effort into something
but i will
and so to them it just looks like magic
now i love that so much that it becomes
very easy for me to use identity
statements
okay so we've got motivation
we're getting amped about it it matters
to us for some reason now we've got
identity statements i'm the type of
person that i'm the type of person that
works so hard people assume it's magic
i'm the type of person that works so
hard at something that people just
assume i'm naturally talented okay i
love that i love saying that about
myself i love knowing that it's true i
love knowing that i can trust myself to
put in the time and the energy to own it
because
i'm the type of person that knows
information is really power and that if
i go in and i work and i get better at
this thing then i'm going to be able to
outperform other people right skills
have utility rule number eight don't
compare yourself
this is one of the most common frames
ever worth
being good enough being right being
smart
because these are very fragile ways to
think of yourself and i understand the
temptation because it feels really good
when you do feel worthy it feels really
good when you are right it feels really
good to actually be the best at
something
but the truth of the world just the
truth of the world
it is this way
you're always going to encounter
somebody better stronger faster more
pious more worthy more whatever
so if you live in a world of comparison
it will rob you of your joy
even people who like michael jordan if
you put him right now up against
most rookies the rookie's going to win
rookies younger faster hungrier
michael's just lost a step he's gotten
old
so if he were trying to make his life
about his glory in that period let's say
he lives 80 years if he's living for the
glory of 20 years that's the most
heartbreaking life i can imagine
so you're going to move in and out of
these moments where you are a badass to
where you're not a badass
don't value yourself for that
value yourself for something that is
anti-fragile
being smart being right being good being
worthy they are very fragile thanks
because sometimes you won't be it simply
is this way
valuing yourself for being a learner on
the other hand for trying
that's anti-fragile
because the more somebody attacks you
for being dumb
but you build your self-esteem around
learning
the first thing i think when someone
says i'm dumb is awesome in what way
because i view myself in these 10-year
windows
and i know
the same people that were laughing at me
when i became an entrepreneur knew
nothing about it and i was who's the kid
in the server room and i was the only
one with an office that had no windows
and there were like nine other computers
in my room and nobody knew who i was and
the only contribution i made the phone
calls was to say goodbye at the end of a
conference call i'm not kidding
ten years later
i own
a billion dollar business
who the [ __ ] is laughing
now but it only worked because i didn't
mind looking stupid
it only worked because i wasn't asking
myself whether i was worthy or whether i
deserved it
i just asked myself am i leaving it all
out on the field yes or no
am i learning yes or no and if i'm not
i didn't go oh that makes me a bad
person
i went i need to change my actions to
get a different result
and once you start thinking like that
and you literally value yourself
for how hard you're trying how much
you're learning how willing you are to
accept when you fall in your face so you
don't try to get out from under it or
campaign to convince people that you're
better than you really are
on where you're at
because once you're real about it then
you can make progress but if your energy
cycles go to [ __ ] yourself you'll
never get out of it rule number nine
execute big elon musk is gonna terraform
mars that's all i need to say to myself
elon musk is gonna terraform mars and
all of a sudden i'm like oh yeah like
i'm thinking really small so
pushing yourself to go to that next
level that next level that next level
until it's
so absurdly big that it's
that's not even true it's going to say
so absurdly big that it terrifies you
but it's really like
the big thinking comes down to what do
you really want to accomplish if i said
whatever you were going to try you were
going to succeed at it's a very famous
question i am sadly not thinking of this
on the spot
if you knew that you were going to
succeed at whatever you tried what would
you try so for me like my whole thing is
i want to pull people out of the matrix
who's done that the best not pulled them
out of the matrix but use the path that
i think is the right path which is
narrative so who's the narrative the
best disney okay disney is a massive
company they've been in business for
like 75 or 80 years i mean which is
absolutely crazy um so okay cool i'm
going to outperform them since they've
done it the best and i have no interest
in being second want to be first okay
there it is now that's not terraforming
mars by any stretch of the imagination
but
that's pretty big so
thinking like that i think is important
because one you're going to be able to
rally people you're going to be able to
get them excited but you've got to back
all the way back from a 75 80 year time
horizon to what do i do today
so that's where i find that people break
down it's not that they're not able to
dream big they can dream big but they
can't execute big and that's where
i think people really fall down and the
one key to all of this to being able to
execute big to allow yourself to believe
that you can execute against that is to
believe that you can learn anything so i
was just telling somebody last night um
that
it
was like a so
blanked because the person i was with
i'll just say this because my mind is
like sketching out if you guys don't
know tony gonzalez the football player
he's amazing check him out that dude's
mindset absolutely incredible i invited
him on the show in fact that's who i was
with last night if you're wondering why
i'm bringing this up uh and he said that
he didn't want to until he conquers the
next part of his life and i thought
jesus for somebody that's done what he's
done to be like it's not enough yet
that's pretty interesting so executing
big the key is
that you've got to believe that you can
do anything you set your mind to you've
got to be you've got to believe that
you're able to
execute against all of that stuff that
you can learn that and that really is
the key to go into something that's
completely unknown and as i was telling
tony last night if i were to
um tomorrow wake up and have disney
studio at my control i think i would so
i know that i have to become someone new
in order to execute against that vision
and it's your willingness to become that
person to accept that you're not that
person right now today but that you can
become that person that's the important
part and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
focus on cellular energy cellular energy
is going to be what you need to focus on
and
i can't tell you how much i hate that i
have to pay attention to my body in
order to achieve the things that i want
to achieve i want to just be able to
work around the clock but i know if i
try to do that i won't be cognitively
optimized and i won't have the energy
that i need so
when i go give talks oftentimes i'll end
up after the talk
answering questions and my record is i
once stood in a hallway with whatever 50
people around me answering questions
without even stopping to pee for 11 and
a half hours
now by the end of it people like how the
hell are you doing this
and the answer was because there are two
types of energy there's
psychological energy right
you're exhausted right imagine it oh you
know those days
you're wiped out
but you got that one song
you put that song on and you still got a
little ass shaking left in you and you
can just feel it it changes your mood
you're ready to get up you're ready to
get down
that's psychological energy okay we can
actually make you suddenly feel like you
have this burst of energy
the other part the one that won't let
you down is real cellular energy now
within your cells are a whole bunch of
these things called mitochondria
mitochondria are separate little
organelles okay they have their own dna
they are not you but they are inside
your cells and they are the power plant
of your body and if you don't do things
to push your mitochondria to stay razor
sharp productive to proliferate you just
won't be able to generate the energy
this is why i'm always telling people
you are having a biological experience
whatever this is your body may have been
given to you by god fair enough but he
gave you a body and now you have to deal
with the realities of going through life
in a body that if you're not eating
right you're not exercising you will not
be able to generate the atp which makes
you feel like you can go and conquer
mountains and do whatever you want but
if you really don't have the energy then
that's a nightmare this goes back to
being tired is a unique ring of hell it
is just absolutely miserable so you're
going to have to get your diet right
which is probably the number one thing
to get your energy levels up at a
cellular level you got to get your diet
right and then to
really push things you want to start
exercising and then another one going
back to one of our early questions cold
exposure is another way to get your
vascular system going to get your
ability to generate atp
up high because cold exposure has a
tremendous impact on your mitochondria
okay so getting that right i think is
going to solve a lot of problems for you
and you may even need to go and get your
thyroid levels checked like there's
really could be a lot going on
biologically so to put it all into the
language of a habit you're gonna go to
bed early however early you need to go
to bed to not set an alarm number two
when you wake up
don't eat you're gonna work out work out
fasted okay i would highly recommend
that you lift weights rather than doing
a bunch of cardio
and then next meditation you'll be
shocked how far that goes
and then we want to
get some cold exposure in there if we
can that would be a really great way to
get you going and as far as diet goes
making sure when you do eat
and try to do intermittent fasting so
that you have call it a 16 hour fasting
window and an eight-hour feeding window
and so you're going to push your first
meal back to post-workout and then when
you eat you're going to make it whole
foods so you're going to be eating green
leafy vegetables you're going to be
eating meat if you eat meat that's
absolutely fine
no processed foods if you can avoid it
you should be
less than ten percent of what you eat
should be processed obviously zero is
the ideal
but realistically if you can make less
than ten percent of it processed you're
going to be gold if you do that all the
time you're going to feel like a million
bucks you you just cannot overestimate
how big of a deal sleep diet and
exercise make it is
life-changing and it's the one thing
most people aren't willing to do but if
you want cellular energy that's the
habit you're gonna have to get in
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and you
get motivated the sign says you have a
35 chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action but when you
watch a video you get motivated and you
create a specific plan of action that
number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video your number jumps to 95
chains of you actually following through
on the plan you set for yourself so i
want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week leave it
down in the comments below so i can
celebrate you
you're going to set rules in your life
i don't care if you've got motivation i
don't care if i have motivation i get
out of bed in 10 minutes or less every
day no matter what no excuses but tom
your leg has snapped off at the knee i
don't care i'm getting out of bed in 10
minutes or less but tom you only got 45
minutes of sleep i don't care i'm
getting out of bed in 10 minutes or less
i have a hard and fast rule it's what i
call a bright line there are bright
lines in my life there is no excuse to
lay in bed there is no rationalization
nothing matters it does not matter
has it been 10 minutes since you woke up
then you got to get yourself out of bed
it's that simple and every day if i miss
and when i miss i miss by seconds but if
i miss i confess to my wife if i miss
i'll even confess on camera and let
people know hey i didn't get out of bed
in 10 minutes or less now keep in mind
it was probably 10 minutes and one
second but even then if the clock is
ticked over to the 11th minute i gotta
wrap myself out because i don't tolerate
that in myself i have that hard and fast
rule it is a bright line and i act in
accordance now the reason that i had to
use bright lines is i used to in my
mid-20s i used to lay in bed for four
and five hours a day every day if i
could get away with it now if you don't
know this quote live by it one can have
no smaller or greater mastery than
mastery over oneself that's da vinci da
vinci did amazing things with his life i
wanted to do equally amazing things with
mine and if that's the game that we're
playing if i can construct my belief
system if i can choose at any moment
to believe something that's more
empowering than i was believing the
moment before
and that that will actually find its way
into my actions
allow me to do things that i couldn't do
the moment before
then it's like that moment in the matrix
where nia realizes he knows kung fu
and that's like as funny as that is
that's how i think about life to me the
very fundamental purpose of life
is to find out how many skills
i can acquire
that have utility
and then put that utility to the test
in service
of something greater than myself
how many skills can i acquire that have
utility put that utility to the test in
service of something greater than myself
that is for me the purpose of life now i
don't actually want to know kung fu that
is not the mission that i'm here to live
but i knew that i had to identify my
mission so what was going to be my
mission
mother teresa has an amazing quote
nobody will act for the many
but people will act for the one
and that really struck me
because i realized they were right i was
looking at this global pandemic of ill
health
and i wasn't
moving into action
but thinking about my mom and my sister
or the uncle i had who ate himself to
death when i was 12 years old
that made me want to act
can you describe what you mean by going
into the darkness i can
alright so
going into the darkness i think
everybody is motivated by two different
things one you have the beautiful things
in your life uh the things that are
going well the things that you're
grateful for the things you're moving
towards instead of a way you have a
compelling vision of your future it's
something that you're very excited about
um all of those things are the beautiful
things now the flip side of that
equation are the
things that uh it's people that doubt
you it's haters it's um things you're
moving away from it's fear-based things
it's something that you absolutely
refuse to let happen so one that is
incredibly potent to me are the people
that want to see me fail so it's very
different than people who just think
you're going to fail i actually don't
have a lot of um
aggression towards people like that but
people that want me to fail
those people i have a lot of aggression
for and i find in very acute
moments
the darkness serves you better
in very acute moments now the light the
things you're moving towards the things
that are beautiful the things that
you're grateful for all of that is the
only winning strategy long term because
the darkness becomes corrosive you start
to become bitter you start to be angry
you stop being optimistic you stop
seeing things in a way that's empowering
and positive and i mean just thinking
about the deep limbic system when it
gets inflamed you perceive things as
negative i think negativity stops people
from making progress there's a whole
host of neurological reasons and sort of
mindset reasons why i think that being
negative over the long run becomes very
very detrimental and holds you back but
from an acute standpoint they've done
studies on this if you want someone to
be able to endure more pain the surest
way to get people to endure more pain is
to let them get angry let them be
aggressive and in doing that people are
able to withstand in the clinical trials
i'll say that it's probably more than
this but in clinical trials they're able
to withstand 30 percent more pain so
just straight being able to take more
pain anger and aggression lets you do 30
more so
that's why i think in acute ways and
short term bursts that the darkness hey
tom what's your best advice for someone
just graduating from college with no
sense of direction and no job go get
lost go explore go do things that
interest you dive deep
don't prematurely optimize so this is
something that i think is missing in
people's lives today if you don't know
what you want to pursue then don't start
pursuing something with all your might
it is very okay to be dirt poor it is
very okay to be broke like in that early
period of your life your early 20s man
it is so
okay to not be making a lot of money as
long as you're able to eat and you would
be startled by how little money that
takes
it's okay go out discover play
bumble around do whatever it takes to
begin to discover the things that really
give you energy
that will serve you incredibly well
because feeling alive
that's the name of the game
there's a gap between who people are and
what they tell you they want to
accomplish because in the beginning i
hired everyone everyone right
not because i'm super smart and thought
hey i should there was no one else right
like we had the smallest handful of
people ever
um and so i started doing the
interviewing as i was doing it i started
realizing god these guys tell me they
want to do something amazing with their
life and if you just listen like wow
yeah like i want to be on your team dude
you're going to do amazing stuff and
then you realize they can't execute on
that dream so why can't they
they don't have the mindset yet like
there's uh you could do an entire
podcast series on how to get the mindset
but i'll just use carol dweck and her
amazing book mindset as well up there
too somewhere i'm sure such a good book
i see simon sinek up there who is also
very influential in us uh and she says
some people either believe they're smart
as they're ever gonna be and that's that
so they're gonna be ego protective and
they're gonna you know try to thwart
anything that makes them feel like
they're not the smartest person or
whatever and then there's people with a
growth mindset and they realize i'm not
the smartest person and i'm certainly
not as smart as i could be yeah so even
if i am the smartest person ever lived i
could get a little bit smarter
and so when they're confronted with
contradictory information they learn and
i remember this was a piece of advice
that my father-in-law gave me that i
promptly ignored and don't worry i've
since apologized to him and
very much
adopted this mentality but he said the
most important thing in business is to
know more about the topic than anybody
else in the room and if you don't see an
echo of that in my preparation for the
interviews um and i'm not doing a good
job of explaining it that was something
that when he said it i'm so sad to
report that it did not hit me but for
whatever weird reason it really stuck
with me and it was one of those things
that i thought about and thought about
and thought about and then it finally
manifested itself and me realizing that
to get good at anything whether that's
business whether that's interviewing it
really is that level of preparation it
is about going above and beyond to get
good at something and i was thinking
about this last night at the event and
there's always like a thousand questions
that i get asked about how you build a
business um you know whatever your dream
is how do you go and actually manifest
it and the honest answer to everything
is
get better get better and i've had
really talented
artists begin reaching out to me on
instagram because obviously that's a
huge focus for us and the next phase is
going to be getting writers getting
artists
bringing them together creating amazing
comic books in phase one
and they'll have like a really small
following and they'll say you know like
what what am i doing wrong what's the
secret and the truth is
even though they're really good
they've got to get a lot better and when
you can be world class but admit that
you're not yet
undeniable cause there's unfortunately a
lot of people that are world class like
think about it you make it to the
olympics your whole life you've been
busting your you finally make it you're
one of the best in your country
truly a world-class player but you
come in seventh eighth
it's you haven't gotten to the point
where you're so good that you can't be
ignored and that like
in today's world where social media
rules everything and anyone can get on
there create noise
you've got to find a way to cut through
the clutter and the way to cut through
the clutter one of there's more and i
will recommend perennial seller by our
boy ryan holiday
really interesting book really excited i
think we've booked him for like november
that'll be a lot of fun
but is in his book he talks about
several of the other things you're going
to do but i'll say that the most
important one is to get so good that you
cannot be ignored cannot be ignored so
if you're being ignored by the way the
world has told you that you've not yet
gotten to where you want to get to so
everybody knows my obsession with disney
read the disney biography in times of
trouble disney always came back around
to make the product better is it
possible to fully grow into your
potential achieve your huge goals and
continue on that journey of the mind
whilst he used whilst which i respect
while still enjoying getting drunk and
partying i didn't see that coming
or are they completely mutually
exclusive so here's what i think about
that i am a big believer that if you're
going all out you are grinding it out
you leave it on the field because i'm
telling you right now monday through
friday if i am awake
i am working or working out period in
fact now these days i read while i'm
working out which i never did before we
could do a whole episode on how i've
made that finally work um
but that
process
one requires that you love what you're
doing so let me just make that
abundantly clear i love what i'm reading
about i love what we're trying to build
all of it just amazing it gives me more
energy than it takes away now once you
have that
the really wanting to actuate your
potential and going after it every day
and knowing i'm going to bed now because
i have left it all out on the field and
i'm telling you there are times during
the day where i'm like let me just look
at reddit for like five minutes i just
like for five minutes i can't do it it's
so embedded in me to want to be the
person that i say out loud to actually
be internally that that's when i go and
i start looking at instagram replying to
comments doing research whatever so
doing that
playing that hard every day
leads me to when i want to stop and go
shake my
even if it's a random tuesday i'll go do
that because i know how hard i've played
every day i know how much i'm willing to
bleed for my goals so this is not about
uh emotional austerity this is not about
grinding yourself into into the dirt
first of all it's doing something you
love so that as you're grinding and
going that hard it's something that you
just
want to do
then
on the other side because you're going
that hard that you just don't have the
guilt that most people have when you
take time off and relax and chill so
when i'm working i am all the way in and
when i'm relaxing i'm all the way in
your talent and intelligence are not
fixed they're malleable
so
you suck at skateboarding because you're
afraid of pain
so the only thing you need to know right
now the point is not to avoid the pain
and you need to stop asking yourself
what's the least you can do to get good
and you need to start asking yourself
what's the most you can bear to become
great
once you understand the whole point is
to let the suffering and the pain harden
you into becoming the version of
yourself that you need to become in
order to execute at the highest level to
be world class at anything and stop
avoiding it stop being afraid of it and
start understanding for what it really
is which is the thing that shapes you so
my entire youth i feared pain i moved
away from pain if something was
emotionally or physically difficult i
avoided it and i remember being in the
gym one day and going
will you stop asking like what's the
least you need to do to consider it a
full week workout because it was like
could i stop now could i stop now could
i stop now and i was like do you want
the muscles or do you want to like put
on a show that you showed up like you
showed up right like because the muscles
demand what the muscles demand like you
have to break them down you have to push
you have to do more like so it is purely
a question of how much you're willing to
bear because there's never going to be
enough you could have always done more
how receptive should i be to the
opinions of others of me when i firmly
believe i'm doing the right thing for
myself so i think it is always good to
scan the opinions of other people even
when they are hostile even even when
they are
overtly meant as an attack to really
look at that and say is there any truth
in this here's the great news when
people attack you they almost always go
for something real it is very rare that
somebody tries to attack you for
something that isn't real so really look
at that thing and figure out okay is
there some truth in here is there um
something that i can address because if
they're hitting you with something
that's true and that if you fixed that
you'd be in a more powerful position
then it's very wise to listen to the
opinions of other people
having said that you need to think more
about yourself and you need to trust
your vision more than you worry about
what other people think it's going to
sting when people don't like what you're
doing or don't believe in you or
whatever
but at the end of the day if you look at
it and there's truth take the truth make
an adjustment don't worry about anything
else it's just that's going to make you
more powerful if there's no truth in it
and it stings then just let it go and
focus on what it is you're trying to
accomplish but at the end of the day
this is all being driven by the goal so
if something they say can help you get
the goal you're going to take it if
something they say hurts but can't help
you reach your goal you're going to
ignore it it's that simple right now
between me and the person i want to be
between you and the person you want to
be there is a gap of skill set and
that's it
but once you know your mission and once
you believe
that you can accomplish anything you set
your mind to
then you can do the extraordinary now
for me getting out of that space of
being lost of not knowing what i wanted
to do with my life
it all came down to needing to earn
credibility with myself
in very small incremental ways
this is me 60 pounds ago
and i knew if i was going to accomplish
anything in my life i was going to have
to get control of my mind
now ironically there's two ways to get
control of your mind way number one is
directly going to the mind which can be
very scary can be very daunting very
ethereal it's ephemeral it's hard to
grab on to it's hard to touch
but way number two is through the body
and so i decided that my kung fu
was going to be to get very good at
developing my body and in that process i
was going to learn about nutrition which
would allow me to help my mom and my
sister in that process i was going to
earn credibility with myself and earning
credibility with yourself is so
important
do it in microwaves for me just showing
up to the gym every day was a micro
victory i said i was going to do it and
i did it now you have to understand i
hate working out so for all of you crazy
people that get an endorphin rush from
running
i hate you all
running for me is like being stuffed
into a meat grinder there is absolutely
nothing pleasurable about it whatsoever
so whatever neurological thing you guys
get that you've been blessed with i have
not been blessed with that so for me
showing up in the gym sucks eating a
bowl of ice cream is awesome and so
getting
to
getting to a better place for me
was a totally different journey
thank you
and what that was was just showing up
every day and putting in the work it was
reading about human metabolism and
understanding how what i eat impacts my
body it was earning a little bit of
discipline every day knowing that well i
did it yesterday i can do it again today
it was not eating something that i
wanted to eat and most importantly and
if you're taking notes write this down
it was about changing my identity
because at the end of the day
identity and values drive behavior
preach
identity and values drive behavior so if
you want to make a change you have to
change your vision of who you are
you have to begin telling yourself a
different narrative and the narrative
you tell yourself about yourself is
everything and if you tell yourself that
you're a scared undereducated kid from
tacoma whose family has never
accomplished anything let me tell you
what you will become
a scared under-educated kid from tacoma
who never accomplishes anything because
that's what you believe
you tell yourself that story enough and
it will become real
but on the flip side you could tell
yourself a story of you're a learner
you learn faster than most people you're
willing to put in more work than most
people you're willing to read more books
than most people you're willing to spend
an inhuman amount of time every day
improving your mind simply by getting
new ideas into the system and that you
will admit that you're wrong faster than
anybody else that you won't let your ego
get in the way and you tell yourself
that story over and over and over so
when somebody comes and tells you how
stupid you are that you're just a kid
from tacoma you go you're right that's
amazing thank you for pointing out that
flaw because now that i'm aware of it i
can improve it because i'm the learner
and once i switched my narrative to
being the learner it didn't matter where
i started it only mattered where i was
trying to go and as long as i had that
clarity then i could execute because i
believed i could do anything i set my
mind to without limitation it's
important to me to have the balls to
look at the biggest problems we face as
a society and say that's my problem to
solve right obesity
metabolic disease
the slide towards illegal health however
you want to categorize it that's my
problem like i don't even wake up
thinking that's my business partner's
problem that's my problem now i'm
working with my business partners
because they're very sharp guys
but at the end of the day like i own
that responsibility i grew up in a
morbidly obese family so for me it was i
needed to have a mission that was so big
and so compelling that it gave me energy
that i could show up every day and fight
for people that i could think about
there's an awesome quote often
attributed to mother teresa that says
nobody will act for the many but people
will act for the one so if there's
someone you can picture someone you know
someone you love like you'll go to
battle for them so
i knew i'll show up every day and fight
for my mom and my sister and i know that
they're gonna die too early if we can't
figure out how to solve this problem of
making food that people want to eat
tastes good and so that became the
mission of the company was to end
metabolic disease and to do it by making
food that people can choose based on
taste and it happens to be good for them
that there is one
truth that you have to burn into your
nervous system now can i remember where
i first heard this
but your network is your net worth
the people that you meet the
relationships that you cultivate they
are going to be
that next phase in your development they
are going to be that next relationship
that next partnership that next thing
introduction that turns into something
that allows you to scale and grow and
get beyond yourself because that is the
thing about scaling you will never
scale
if it's just you you have no leverage so
you've got to meet other people that can
get the ball rolling that can introduce
you that can give you that key piece of
information that you need to really go
on and do something so get out there
meet people be yourself let your freak
play by introduce yourself stand super
awkwardly next to somebody that you want
to meet like i did tonight
and just say what's up introduce
yourself tell them what you're up to and
if you want to be interesting be
interested ask them find out what
they're about find out what makes them
tick that's the secret that'll get them
rolling and then you can see if there's
a real connection and if there is from
that something can build
so get out there so when i hear people
where their reaction is to
about a problem like let you and i were
talking you being hispanic is working
against you jason you being an
african-american it's working against
you like you're gonna have to go uphill
but now what you're gonna sit and
complain about it because it won't help
you right so if you have a goal it's
like it does suck that women have to
work harder to get to the same place
that has a white male in america that i
have to get to but if it is true if
we're all going to accept that it's true
we can all sit there and go we need to
focus on the systems fair enough and i'm
glad that some people do that the other
option though is to say well i
completely control me
and the one thing i will tell any human
being alive right now there is always
room for the best
and once you're able through your skills
that have utility to move somebody else
closer to their goal you will become a
hot commodity no matter what no matter
what
okay think about the scientists what
were the scientists after world war ii
right before they were scientists for us
they were nazis but we were way happy to
let go of that because they had crazy
skills that we needed right
so really what it comes down to is what
are your skills like if you've got
skills that can be used to build
something beautiful to do something
wonderful to the world to help people
move towards their goals that will
excite the masses because they they want
that thing that you're going to create
that it's going to improve people's
lives
but only thing that mattered in all of
that was you got really good at
something and somewhere along the way we
lost that the punch line is no matter
what you do to the system you
you as an individual need to get
extraordinary
at something
and so my encouragement to people is go
get extraordinary like don't worry about
whether the system is broken or not we
built quest a billion dollar company in
less than five years coming out of the
great recession
so
more what was it in the great depression
more millionaires were created in the
great depression than any other time in
history it's like
it just comes down to somebody goes
honestly this is how i react the system
is too big and complicated i'm too
afraid to try to get caught up in fixing
that i'm too big of a chicken there i
just said it i'm too big of a chicken to
deal with that but i can deal with
myself i can go get extraordinary
right so focus on that go get
extraordinary go become the best of
whatever it is you want to be but go
become the best of it and see how the
world opens to you how do you completely
start over in life when your past
mistakes won't let go of you all right
let's be really clear
you won't let go of your past mistakes
that that is just the gospel truth so
you've got to work at letting those go
now the only thing that i've found that
works is the following to understand
that they don't move you towards your
goals so for me putting in
not quite a bright line but
really
taking the impact theory belief system
which by the way you can download now by
going to impacttheory.com signing up for
our newsletter which i kill myself to
make those newsletters amazing so go
there now and one of your incentives for
doing so is the 25-point bullet belief
system those are the 25 things you need
to do to your mind to make sure that
you're optimized for success one of
those things is we only believe that
which moves us towards our goals now the
reason that i put that into my own life
is because i found that i would obsess
over things that had happened in the
past either something that happened to
me or something that i did and you get
into this really weird cycle that is
absolutely
obsessive
because of that it becomes hardwired
because of that it becomes easier to
think about because of that you think
about it more often it begins to just
occupy a lot of cycles and crowds out
your ability to get other things done so
i didn't know how to break out of that
pattern because like you i thought it
was something that was happening to me
rather than something that i could
control and so i had to flip it and
realize okay i'm in my life at the
absolute foundational layer of
everything that i do
and believe i'm going to make sure that
it's something that moves me towards my
goals so if obsessing over the past move
me towards my goals i would do it but it
doesn't and so i don't that is the only
thing that i found that i have a belief
that is so powerful and all-encompassing
in my life that i should do what moves
me towards my goals that anything even
something that i would otherwise be
prone to obsessively return to
i use basically techniques from
cognitive behavioral therapy also known
as cbt
where i will stop myself it doesn't mean
that i'm not having those initial
thoughts but it means that i interrupt
those initial thoughts because it's not
moving me towards my goal i move that
aside and then i go focus on the thing
that is going to move me towards my goal
which may be an empowering thought to
reframe that negative thing as something
positive to remind myself that i'm good
i'm worthy i'm whatever i need to do in
order to get moving and get going or
just ask myself have you learned from
that mistake and if you have
then
go you've got the lesson move forward
nothing else matters cycling through it
isn't going to help so that is my advice
it is very doable cognitive behavioral
therapy interrupt those patterns make
them habit loop triggers for something
empowering i very much used to be task
oriented i have lovingly said that what
my parents imbued me with was a slave
mentality keep my head down do as little
work as possible and avoid punishment at
all costs that's how i thought about
things certainly how i thought about
school it's how i thought about a job
it's how i thought about most of the
relationships in my life it was about
avoiding conflict it was
not about having strong core beliefs it
was really um
getting by getting through life like
trying to
um you know get through the week so that
you can enjoy yourself on the weekend
and love your family and don't get me
wrong they had really amazing intentions
and they wanted me to enjoy my life but
there were just things that they saw is
inalienable there were you just couldn't
change them and so
that put me in
just thinking about whatever was right
before me so oh i need to get an a okay
you know this is what i'll do to get my
a
and
the grades is a perfect example because
the real goal should have been learning
it should have been knowledge it should
have been me going hey the system
doesn't actually really give me the
things that i want and so pushing back
against that and trying to figure out
what i need to do to actually educate
myself but i didn't do that because the
task before me was get an a that's just
what you did in my family you got good
grades and so cheating was a perfectly
reasonable solution to that now when i
went to college i realized wait a second
this is supposedly the thing that i love
most i was studying film so uh if i
really love this then why would i cheat
if i'm going to try to get a career out
of this again why would i cheat and if
i'm taking on massive amounts of college
debt to learn about this why would i
cheat it doesn't make sense and so in
that i switched from that task-oriented
mindset to really thinking bigger about
my goals there were things in life that
i wanted to achieve that i wanted to
accomplish and i had to then reverse
engineer what i needed to do to get
there what you think about yourself
is the ultimate
goal it's the ultimate thing it's the
ultimate reward or punishment
but what you think about yourself
is at the end of the day the single most
important thing and so beginning to have
a relationship with yourself of sitting
quietly and this may be one of the
reasons that meditating is so important
that you can actually sit quietly
think about who you are now what you
think about yourself who you want to
become what price you're willing to pay
to get there and then actually going
down that path to become that person
that at the end of the day is the thing
that is going to bring you happiness and
fulfillment but you really have to think
about who you want to become
and to not be trapped by your past but
do that put time and energy into
thinking about what do i want to think
about myself and quite honestly what do
i think about myself right now if you
steer by that it becomes very easy to
ignore other people
everybody lean in nice and close
self-compassion it's probably the most
important thing that you can do for
yourself is when you [ __ ] up you need to
forgive yourself okay so
that's
really really important so and i'll walk
you through an example uh about whatever
20 minutes ago
i get really frustrated when people are
trying to tell me something but they're
whispering that redlines me in a way
that i can't even begin to tell you and
so it just happened while i'm here live
on camera and i hold myself to a
standard of catching my emotions before
they rise up now this has happened twice
today the first time it happened i
caught myself yay the second time it
happened i was like for real we're doing
this again and i got very frustrated so
i was very disappointed in myself for
that but i need to be compassionate
towards myself forgive myself for that
get better use it as practice and
remember that life isn't performance it
really is about practice
so once you can meet yourself with
compassion then you can begin to let go
of whatever it is that's really your
mindset um you can get back on track you
can refocus and don't wait till monday
and that's a mistake that everybody
makes so if you fall off the wagon like
if i fell off the wagon at 9 58 at 9 59
and back on the wagon so i'm not waiting
even for 10 o'clock like you literally
do it right there at that moment make it
a part of your identity that you're the
type of person that does that so that is
really really critical only
execution matters
burn that into your nervous system get a
tattoo do whatever you need to do to
remind yourself
only execution matters
thinking about it feeling good about it
those are awesome but if you have a
vision of something you're trying to do
become whatever and you don't execute
against it and i don't need you to want
to build a big business if you tell me
you want to be the greatest parent of
all time then i'm going to ask you what
are you doing to execute on that goal
what are you doing how do you define it
what are your deliverables what are the
metrics by which you're judging yourself
and by the way if you don't want a grand
goal you don't need one but then say
what i'm trying to do is get centered
i'm trying to experience happiness even
that you can begin to look at ways that
you can improve that and as bruce lee
said if you always put limits on
everything you do physical or anything
else it will spread into your work and
into your life there are no
limits
there are only plateaus and you must not
stay there
you must go beyond them
even in the statement you can see him
making the choice about what to believe
by saying that there are no limits by
taking something that other people
perceive as a limit it's something
that's stopping him and saying that's
not it's a plateau it's something that i
can push through and you see
what he holds himself accountable to
it's not okay to stay at a plateau it's
okay to have one everybody has them they
happen it's a natural part of the course
of getting better but it is not okay to
stay there and that is a choice that's
not something anyone can hand you it's
something you have to believe to the
core of your soul that it is not okay
to stay in a plateau and it's that
that's gonna push you through it's that
that's gonna make you get up and keep
going but first
you have to recognize that life is cause
and effect you have to recognize that
that choice is a knock on effect you
have to recognize that him merely saying
those words out loud
have a cause and effect they change the
course of his life the expectations that
other people have of him expectations
that he has of himself and because he
understands that he can control
the outside world by first controlling
what's inside by changing his belief
system to match what he wants to
accomplish
he's then able to accomplish
what he did in his life had nothing to
do with luck
it had everything to do with the demands
that he made on himself it had to do
with when he got in the motorcycle
accident people told him he would never
walk again not only did he walk again
all of the major accomplishments that we
think about of being that man
they all came after
they came after he was told he was never
going to walk came after he was told
that he was never going to be able to do
martial arts
but he did it he did the grueling work
of getting better he understood cause
and effect he understood that if he
chose to believe
that he could never do it
that he'd never be able to do it
but that if he chose to believe that by
working out he could get stronger and
get better and get back to it than he
could and that's what he did
so now ask yourself
is your life dictated by luck
or cause and effect
are you in control or is it somebody
else
is someone else in control
or is it you
and if it's you
go build the life that you want because
there's nothing stopping you but you
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there